Jessica Beaumont travaille depuis un an
au CPE idfix à Montréal elle fait partie
des employés d'agence de placement moi
pour une question de flexibilité dans
mes horaires c'est beaucoup plus facile
de quand on a besoin d'un congé même
sans être diplômé en technique
d'éducation à l'enfance son salaire est
plus élevé c'est quelques dollars mais
ça au bout du compte vu que c'est quand
même un travail qui est peu payé à la
base les quelques dollars qu'on a de
plus en agence on va faire vraiment la
différence c'est énorme là quelques
dollars qui pèsent lourd dans le budget
annuel du CPE cette année les
éducatrices d'agence ont coûté 207000
dollars j'avais prévu 140 000 dans mon
budget pour
agence de placement donc j'ai déjà
dépassé mon budget 66000 à peu près les
agences de placement existent depuis
longtemps dans le milieu des garderies
mais elles sont de plus en plus sol
licites form qui ne sait plus quoi faire
pour attirer des candidatures
qu'on puisse attirer les gens qui au
lieu d'aller travailler dans les agences
qui viennent travailler chez nous parce
que là on met des annonces on soit pas
de CV l'autre problème c'est qu'une
grande partie de ces éducatrices
d'agence ne sont pas qualifiés oui on
tire la qualité vers le bas pour les
services c'est au-delà du salaire les
intervenantes font également beaucoup de
temps supplémentaires il y a une charge
de travail importante la ministre de la
Famille Suzanne Roy précise que le
recours aux agences varient d'une région
à l'autre et que si le gouvernement doit
intervenir il le fera nécessité
d'intervenir à ce moment-là on va le
faire mais on va commencer par regarder
le fonctionnement dans les agences les
éducatrices n'ont pas les mêmes
avantages sociaux qu'ils peuvent avoir
un CPE ce n'est pas assez pour
convaincre Jessica Beaumont même après
avoir complété sa formation elle n'a pas
l'intention de quitter son agence
ici jacaudrai Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Montréal